we need to be more 80 20. the team is
not working 80
20 enough you need to approach this
analysis with the 80 20 mentality
so the 80 20 principle or the 80 20
rule or the pareto principle as some
people are calling it
this is the topic for today's video
this principle or rule is so commonplace
in consulting and in many other
industries as well
that this term is almost a cliche
so as important as it is i want you to
really understand
what it's all about why it's used so
frequently in consulting
and what indeed the value of it all is
so let me start here by explaining what
this is all about
and indeed this pareto principle how it
was originally called
was invented by alfredo pareto he was an
italian
economist and he apparently found out
that in italy at that time
80 percent of the land was owned by
20 of the people so 80 20
this relationship this is what it's all
about and this now permutes in lots of
other areas of society of work
and the common implication here for work
is that often
for many many tasks 80
of the results are created by 20
of the activities 80 20. so this is the
topic that we are going to talk about
today
so welcome to firm learning my name is
heinrich and on my channel firm learning
i want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career
i'm a former mckinsey management
consultant and on my channel i try to
share my tips
both for soft skills and hard skills
that you need to be successful
so if you want to hear more about that
feel free to subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all my content so
indeed today's topic is the pareto
principle
i will look at it for two directions the
first is actually duplication of it
in analysis that you do and practical
work in your work as a consultant
so how can you leverage this principle
to use it for work that you do together
with the client
but then second i'm also going to talk
about how it's often used
internally so let's dig into it to
better understand
how the pareto principle really works
what you see
here is the typical curve of how such a
pareto relationship really looks like
and indeed the characteristic of this
curve is that in the beginning the curve
has a very high slope that then reduces
over time goes down over time
unless it's almost zero in the very end
but what do you actually see here so on
the x-axis you see the different
elements the different items components
that then create a certain effect and
these components are ordered by their
size
or magnitude or impact right so the
first components are the strongest
biggest
best ones and then the magnitude goes
down and then on the y-axis you see the
effect the
output the outcome of these inputs and
indeed what you can see here is that the
very first components create a
significant portion of the outcome and
then every additional component every
additional item that comes
after it its marginal contribution to
the total result is significantly
diminishing and in the end it's almost
zero so this was maybe a bit theoretical
so let's make it practical where is this
really applied to practice where does
this really exist now a couple of
examples from wikipedia for instance in
the wealth distribution so for many
countries the 80 20 rule
more or less is indicative of the wealth
distribution of the population so the
wealthiest
20 of the people own 80 percent of the
total wealth of the company
another application the healthcare
system so typically twenty percent of
the patients
create eighty percent of the cost of the
healthcare system
in business it might be in sales twenty
percent of the products creating eighty
percent of the revenue
and production 20 of the parts creating
of the problem of the defaults or in
buying 20
of all your suppliers are responsible
for 80
of your cost baseline so these were just
some examples that are found on
wikipedia and other places
in the internet of course this is never
precisely exactly the case
it just gives a rough indication but at
least personally i find it really
fascinating to see that this is a
relationship that you really see
often when you observe things in the
business world or in other areas of your
daily life
so how can you apply this 80 20
principle
in your work as a consultant also as an
employee working in a certain business
function if you just want to understand
your business a bit better because
indeed this pareto analysis is an
analysis that you can do in many many
different types of circumstances
it's usually possible to complete it
with very basic data
and it at least provides one angle one
perspective at the structure of the
business how certain things are working
together in interlinked so let me just
share you one example i was working in a
sales project and we were asking
ourselves how can we serve our customers
in a more cost effective way so one of
the first things that we did is that we
looked at the customer base and we
calculated the contribution margin
for each individual customer so we were
asking ourselves how much
does the company earn with each of these
individual customers
and then we ordered the customers from
the highest to the lowest contribution
margin and then we created the
cumulative curve
and of course no big surprise it was a
pareto relationship meaning that roughly
the 20
of the most profitable customers
contributed to 80
of the profits and then actually in the
end the curve even went down because
there were a couple of customers which
had a negative contribution margin so if
you took the product margin that was
earned by selling certain products to
them and you subtracted what the sales
organization was costing you so the cost
to serve to actually serve these
customers and some of them were negative
and this was a great discussion starter
with the head of sales talking about how
can we further prioritize
these largest most important customers
what ways can we think of to reduce the
cost of sales for the long term for the
end of the sole curve where the moment
we're actually
even losing money also did a couple of
purchasing projects and here this is one
of the first standard analysis as well
so looking at the supplier base and
you're asking yourself how is the spend
of the company
distributed among the suppliers and
again
often you also see this strong
concentration of a spend with a couple
of suppliers and then this
big long tail and here often again the
question is how can we optimize this can
we consolidate some of the spend of the
suppliers
in the long tail with larger suppliers
to simplify the organization and
potentially also get
volume discounts next example a project
where we looked into the product
portfolio of a company
again same thing per rate analysis you
notice that a small share of the
products create the vast majority of the
revenue
and the question then is what can we do
with the long tail now of course to not
be misunderstood here this parade
analysis is a very basic tool
it's very quick and easy to do it in the
very beginning this will of course
not be the major insight of such a
project this will not be the end of it
all but it's often a good
effective first starting point to get
for yourself also good understanding of
how this business is structured and
potentially you can also spark some
first discussions with your client
counterparts or colleagues about certain
topics that you no further want to look
into into your project
but before we jump into it i want to
introduce you to the sponsor of today's
video
and this sponsor is skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people you can
explore new skills
deepen your passions and get lost in
creativity there are classes on
marketing personal
branding presentation skills and many
more all of these are topics that are
highly applicable to a career in
consulting banking or corporate
and the best thing is that i made a
slight writing class for skillshare so
you can access and enjoy it as a
skillshare member
personally i recently took the class
productivity master class
principles and tools to boost your
productivity from the fellow youtuber
ali abdal
it's a great class it taught me many new
aspects of productivity and i very much
enjoyed how you applied the pareto
principle or the 80 20 rule to
productivity
classes on skillshare are specifically
curated for learning there are no
ads they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and the best thing is that it's less
than ten dollars a month with an annual
subscription skillshare created a
special offer for subscribers of this
channel from learning and so the first
thousand subscribers of me click on the
skillshare link in the video description
we get a free trial of the skillshare
premium membership i hope this helps you
to explore your creativity
check it out link in the video
description so now let's look at the
other way how the 80 20 rule is often
used in consulting in similar industries
and this is for the internal
organization of work for the
prioritization
of the team also the time management if
you like and here the basic idea is that
as with all the other things
often 20 of the effort of the work of a
team
leads to 80 of the outcome and this of
course the other way around means that
the last 20
of output the last 20 of polishing
something
takes 80 of the whole time so the basic
question is is this really necessary
is this really required and of course
here the meme
behavior of a consulting partner is to
walk into the team room
and say something like hey let's be 80
20. but then he or she proposes a super
detailed analysis which will take the
whole team weeks and months
really to complete with no understanding
at all what is really
absolutely required and what is just a
nice add-on right so often it's always a
little bit of a joke let's be 80 20
because
unfortunately or for whatever reason
many many things many analysis that
consultants do
are not 80 20 but there's often the big
push
to be extremely diligent to be extremely
detailed and of course there might be
good reasons for that but still the
whole idea
is important and does afterward also
play a big role in consulting
and it happens all the time that for
instance as a new team
joining a new client for a new project
there might be a business with different
business units
five business units for instance but
then you might decide to
only look into the biggest two or three
business units and
actually might have lots of ideas lots
of improvement potential
for business unit four and five but
these business units are so small
even if you improve their profit by
twenty percent it's just such a little
part of the overall profit baseline for
the company that the impact would just
not be good enough and you would be much
better off if you really would focus on
the larger three business units and of
course considerations like that break
down up to the activities of really the
most
junior people in the team room so you
might be a business analyst working on
an analysis and you get
some data from the client and you do an
analysis but then you realize that
certain pieces are missing
the client did not provide the full data
of certain products certain business
units whatever certain data points are
still not there and here of course the
natural inclination is that yes you need
this you might need to spend another
week to talk to another person who can
provide you with this data as well with
many many similar tasks
it's very easy to invest a lot of time
into really getting something from 90
200 percent and you're just so important
to always have the bigger picture in
mind is this really helping you to
answer the questions that you want to
answer
or aren't 80 or 90 of the information
not good enough to actually get exactly
these answers is this additional 10 to
20 percent of
result really required does this even
help your toys so if you'd like to
simplify it in the end
being 80 20 means to be pragmatic to not
over complicate
things to realize and understand when
what you have is just good enough for
what you need
or to use another meme consulting phrase
the opposite of being 80 20 is to
boil the ocean right to get really
everything done to put as much
energy into something that you will be
able to really boil the ocean so
ladies and gents let's not boil the
ocean please but let's be a bit more 80
to any here
so i hope you found this interesting and
insightful now i'd love to hear from you
let me know in the comments what are
your experiences with the 80 20
principle
what is your favorite application of
that principle i'd love to hear that
so as always if you liked the video if
you took any value out of it at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on all my
content
i'm releasing new videos every single
saturday
in addition to that feel free to follow
me on instagram my handle is firm
learning
i've also an email list sign up in the
video description
and i wanna end by saying thanks to all
the members of from learning
you're really making a big contribution
to the channel and of course i also want
to say thank you to skillshare the
sponsor of this video
so if you want to benefit from this free
skillshare trial
check out the link in the video
description so see you next week
very much looking forward to next video
to talking to you again next saturday
so until then bye bye my name is
heinrich this is from learning
cheers